you
how is it blood pressure let's have
another recycle please
yes
the whole operation is expanding with
our research program we're getting new
buildings our staff is growing but we
still find ourselves in need of newer
and better facilities of course it's the
same everywhere at the government
institutes the large private concerns
pharmaceutical laboratories but after
all when you consider the fantastic
growth in medical research step in here
please this is one of our recently
equipped laboratories the University by
the way is quite interested in this
particular experiment we expect some
significant results within the next few
months which quickly dissolve into
entirely new direction I would say yes
to that everyone is familiar with the
explosion medical technology medicine
will continue to grow at a fantastic
rate this we take for granted but in the
excitement we've been overlooking a few
things for example the fact that we in
the profession are losing touch with
each other and each other's work it's a
big science today's medicine it's
becoming increasingly fragmented we're
standing out on a thousand directions
each new discipline has its own maze of
facts and figures its own esoteric
jargon if we lose sight of each other we
could lose sight of the common goal
which is health is it not ideally I
should be aware of all new works being
done and feels related to mind but I
have a hard enough time keeping up my
own field as for the medical students I
don't know how they managed to learn all
they're supposed to as a matter of fact
a lot of very interesting development
have come about indirectly we'll be
running an experiment and several
unfamiliar problems will arise each one
of which leads us on into something
entirely different
new insight new problems new directions
there's no end to it we always have to
be prepared to branch out oh yes
definitely what has happened what
certainly the most is that all the
diverse activity is reduced to a log jam
of information and it will continue to
pile up unless we get better ways to get
it moving we need to disentangle this
vital knowledge and make use of it
this is going to require better methods
of communication better teaching methods
we're expecting a lot of important data
from this experiment of course it's a
little early to be certain but there may
be other applications in chemotherapy
particularly in connection with
cardiovascular surgery in surgery you
have to teach largely by demonstration
this means that you can handle only a
few students at a time
as it is the practicing physician can
scarcely afford the time it takes to
find out whether someone else has done
this before is often longer than the
actual time it takes to run the
experiment yourself we need some means
to amplify the effectiveness of the
expert these men had become a party's in
their field there's a little time to
keep more more data visualization will
increase searches were little Commission
or more necessary no in sort of what you
mean by basic education this is grounded
on the somewhat dubious assumption that
in a given number of years you can learn
the fundamentals of each discipline but
what are the fundamentals these days
like the Turkish later will be thirty
years old
you would have been in school from c-23
years and you still have another 2 maybe
4 years to go in your specialty well
that depends on the field
no take anything you want I don't care
what it is you've got some time to put
in I mean it's something really small
and special like little corner in
dermatology or Pediatrics or something
if you started right now at the rate
things are going you've got three years
reading for the three years you might
get started in three years just going in
so fast three years is going to look
like Wemo and reading is only part of it
you know what you really need is a whole
head full of transistors and a plug
where every time you need it to know
something all you'd have to do is lie
down and lock yourself in
the problem information knowledge lots
of it so much we can scarcely comprehend
the volume the weight of it Rajyam and
weight odd measurements of knowledge
maybe it's not so odd when you think
about it how much you would get lost
very how many powers how many cubic feet
how much desperately needed it prevail
you too much to learn too little time
Jun few teachers too many people who
need to know thing important thing too
much knowledge how can that be how can
there be too much knowledge about curing
disease saving lives how when there's so
much we don't know but you need a better
way to process information evaluate it
assimilate we need better ways to
communicate it clearly and rapidly
better ways to get it where it's needed
[Music]
sometimes it's better to see something
really see or hear something a picture
can be worth a thousand words a picture
can be priceless pictures can see into
the heart
pictures show describe with water
[Music]
[Music]
pictures capture pictures preserve a
picture can go places easier and faster
it can go a lot of places at once
[Music]
the instructor can not actually but an
image of him cat his voice Candice's a
pathologist says that difficulty in
establishing the diagnosis of carcinoma
and the Legion has been hired on we've
got some motion picture film they're
coming up about three minutes a super
stand I went into Southie hang on one
he'll turn around the black makes the
critical differentiation of that he can
pack up his lesson and made it
pictures talk in any language to the
literate to the illiterate pictures can
teach sound can teach they can teach a
lot of things fact pleasure again and
again you still need books
you still need teachers but pictures and
sounds can bring books to life they can
provide the best teachers when and where
they're needed it's a big science
today's medicine it's becoming
increasingly fragmented with dining out
in a thousand directions and each new
discipline has its own maze of facts and
figures its own esoteric jargon if we
lose sight of each other
we could lose sight of a common goal
which is health is it not sounds and
pictures all the old visuals
[Applause]
[Music]